hi thank you for taking my call that's a
while like I do have so many questions I
only limit myself to one I'm a 600-pound
guy with 28 years old he's single get
away from a Hyundai I looked up some
selfies how much weight he says he
weighs over 600 pounds he didn't tell me
the exact weight because I guess he was
kind of embarrassing yeah well I
actually deal a lot with people who are
600 pounds 625 88 this sort of thing so
this is not unusual these days where the
number one will be information in the
world and we're getting more and more
people who are over 400 pounds okay and
so this is not unusual yeah how many
medical conditions is this guy have if
you say he doesn't have any that he went
and he wants to have that surgery where
he can lose weight I don't know what
it's called I forgot he should give us
six months yeah he thought my gastric
bypass yeah she wants to have the bypass
but he has to lose a hundred pounds in
order for them to do it so I already
gave him one of the healthy packs and he
started with that he hasn't done the
liver cleanse because he he just started
on that like three weeks ago a complete
so overweight he's already ran over the
nutrients so I ordered them again the
nutrients and the sweeties but I'm not
really sure if I am came into the riders
we were cable G on three because he has
diabetes no he doesn't have anything he
said okay all right so everything goes
bye-bye anyways so it's over 100 pounds
of body weight so if he weighs 600
pounds you should really take six of
these programs of each of the programs
per month
okay but what I'm going to do is get a
hold of our Quito caramel shakes and our
kilo terrible meal bars and he could
have two meals a day
the keto caramel shake when breakfast
went to dinnertime or you could replace
one of the shakes with a meal bar and
then for one meal a day what it doesn't
matter if it's lunch or breakfast is
dinner time you have steamed vegetables
and eggs
it has say three or four or five or six
eight saw scrambling butter soft coats
of oil wasabi oaks our steamed
vegetables and poultry our steamed
vegetables and fish our steamed
vegetables and red meat
okay portion size everything should fit
on a level on a coffee cup saucer so
we're not looking at you know a
thirty-two pounds so it's take or
anything like that were just looking
very very tiny amounts couple of
tablespoons of red meat bar a couple of
tablespoons of fish or are a couple of
tablespoons of poultry and so on are
three or four eggs but he needs two
meals a day of the keto caramel
supplement meals okay we're talking
about the bar you could have two meals a
day the bar they could have two meals a
day of the other shake or he could have
one meal a day of the shake and one meal
a day of the bar and then I would have
him take a minimum of two really he
should have a minimum of three if it's
not a financial burden ideally he would
take six of the healthy I go with a
heavy-duty stuff healthy brain and heart
pack but a minimum of two a month so we
can take a full dose everything twice a
day then he also need to get two pounds
a month to the rev or evey and it
haven't taken two drivers full before
each meal let absorbing three-year-olds
as you can take one dropper full thirty
minutes for each meal let it absorb
through your old dishes a second dropper
full fifteen minutes for each meal I'll
take two thousand a month to do that
twice sitting and he'll begin to lose a
quarter of a pound to a half pounds to
two pounds a day okay now I really don't
recommend the gastric bypass because
when you get to the point where you're
really doing that sort of thing to lose
the weight
what happens is you really get
deficiencies and oftentimes people die
from a nutritional deficiency and so we
have a problem with that but if that's
obviously his choice
but I wouldn't recommend it give us 90
days it'll be amazing how much weight he
can lose it's not unusual that in 30
days you lose 60 pounds or 60 days you
lose 90 pounds and so on on this program
okay so don't forget it's a diet along
with these supplements and then call us
every two weeks and let us know how this
guy is doing you're welcome to call
anytime and ask your question but don't
wait longer than two weeks okay and the
thing that he will not tell me the way
because I'm told I'm going to have
yourself weight and then let me know as
we go because then I won't know how
you're doing